le département de la réunion aux côtés
des rényon la paix à l'allocation
personnalisée d'autonomie est une
compétence obligatoire du département ce
dispositif contribue au maintien à
domicile des personnes âgées et
dépendantes
à qui s'adresse-t-il
âgées de 60 ans et plus en perte
d'autonomie
vous pouvez bénéficier d'une aide
financière du département pour l'obtenir
vous devez adresser une demande auprès
des services de l'aide sociale aux
adultes une équipe médico social se
rendra chez vous afin d'évaluer votre
situation et vos besoins
la paie acp est versée mensuellement
pour une durée de trois ans renouvelable
cette allocation n'est pas imposable et
le département de la réunion n'applique
pas le recours sur succession pour plus
de renseignements vous pouvez contacter
la za nord au 02 62 28 98 28 lasa sud au
02 62 96 90 60 10 l'aja est au 02 62 46
58 10 8 et la za ouest au 02 62 55 47 47
vous pouvez également contacter la
maison de l'aide à la personne au 0 800
53 000